Luke here at the art boy YouTube channel
and I'm deep in the heart of the Alaskan
mountains I'm using Snow Dogs snowshoes
and skis to cross a 22 Mile path through
the mountains I'm building my own
survival shelters and camping in
blizzards equipment's breaking down and
my body is getting beat up I'm not sure
I can do this but I am sure it's going
to be an interesting
[Music]
video
I'm going to
p
the snow dog's not very good at going
over
logs sled hitch popped up hit me right
in the
teeth oh man feel like I tipped a tooth
on that got to be careful with my money
maker sometimes when an engine gets
flipped over on its side it messes up
the oil and gas and can cause problems
so I'm just going to kind of let this
sit here give it a few minutes and see
if that doesn't fix the
problem all right that seemed to do the
trick
[Applause]
check this out this is one of the old
Road houses during the Gold Rush days
this Trail was used to take supplies
from the coast into the interior of
Alaska to the goldfields and there's
these roadhouses all along the trail and
the mushers would use them to get
supplies and a hot meal and Shelter From
The
Storm oh
man see the old shelves in
here that old wood stove I think I
should probably get out of
here this roof is looking pretty saggy I
probably shouldn't have gone inside
there
[Applause]
that little snow dog weighs just under
300 lb
and it has no reverse on it
so can be a bit of a
[Applause]
pain
oh something just went off with that my
throttle cable just broke so the
throttle Cable's right here and there's
a little screw that holds it in place so
that when you squeeze the handle it
pulls the throttle that old screw's
coming loose and I went and tightened it
up but if it falls out I can't work my
throttle
[Applause]
anymore
my throttle keeps giving me trouble and
I'm having to fix it every few minutes I
still got about 20 mil to go and uh
we're already off to a rough
start
oh
shoot oh that throttle jammed
[Applause]
open oh I'm getting too old for this
it's gotten dark on me I need to find a
place to set up
camp
I'm tired I skipped lunch and I'm
feeling
it going to have a little snack till I
get my energy
up
[Music]
I got to tell you guys I am exhausted
driving that snow dog is a workout and
it got stuck so many times I'm so tired
I don't even want to bother with a
fire
yeah since I don't got a fire going I'm
going to use an old dog mushing trick to
cook my food so I've got an old tuna
fish can and a bottle of heat this is a
fuel additive we put into gas tanks to
keep them from freezing up in the winter
time and it's mostly made out of
isopropyl
alcohol
isopropyl alcohol could be very
dangerous see how the flame is nearly
invisible if you spill isopropyl alcohol
on yourself and light yourself on fire
in the day time you won't even be able
to see it but it burns really clean and
really hot so so it's great for cooking
put some olive oil in the bottom of the
pan the advantage of burning alcohol is
that it burns really clean you can use
it inside the tent like this and it
doesn't stink the place up doesn't make
your food taste
funny I'm done cooking my couscous it
looks like the flame just went out about
5 6 ounces of heat lasted about 20
minutes let's cover that up keep that
warm there we
go got some fresh Alaskan scallops here
got some butter and
garlic cranberry couscous and scallops
cooked in garlic butter that's pretty
good scallops have to be my favorite
Seafood I got a sweet and passion fruit
jelly that I'm going to use to make some
herbal
tea oh it's just passion fruit puree a
little bit of Honey added to it man it
is so
good
between my body heat and the stove this
little tent's pretty warm but it's
melted all the snow that's falling on it
and you can see there's this big pile of
water right
here uh there's another one over
[Music]
here I brought a couple Caribou hides to
sleep on Caribou have these thick Hollow
hairs they're just absolutely amazing to
sleep on you know air mattresses can pop
when you sleep straight on the ground
like this so it's nice to have these
hides instead fold them over just a
little bit get them extra
thick Let's test it
out oh yeah this will
work I got to tell you I'm excited to
get into bed I am tired and beat up got
these down Camp slippers got a pair of
down pants as
well oh I love these down pants and
these down booties they are so nice
probably got too much stuff on right now
but uh I'm cold so I'm okay with
that oh my socks are ever so slightly
wet whenever you have a little bit of
wetness in your socks it'll make your
feet cold took them off and I'm shoving
them down on the bottom of my bag so
they can dry overnight I'll tell you
it's a little bit lumpy and uh I'm using
a log as a pillow but it's not bad but I
am so exhausted I think I'm just going
to go to bed unless I get visited by
Wolves or something in the middle of the
night I'll see you guys in the
morning oh we got a problem roof just
collapsed on
me
there so much ice and snow on the tarpet
broke the Paracord but uh ran out there
and fixed it oh well I guess it was time
to get up anyways when the roof cave is
in on you that's a signal it's time to
get up and get out of bed see got my
socks dried
off oh everything's just wet in here
this tarp traps the heat pretty well and
it melts the snow and so the snow's
turned to slush on the outside and
that's leaking through and I've got
condensation on the inside so every time
I touch the tarp I get
wet got some powdered Tang
here
oh that feels nice you see how the fire
is orange now instead of that invisible
blue color I threw a few wood chips in
there last night and that Ash mixed with
the alcohol makes the Flames orange so
you can see them oh man having that
little alcohol stove under the tarp
really warms it up in here it's
nice all
right oh
woo well let's get this snow dog fired
up oh that throttle switch is so messed
up the machines died on me twice while I
was just sitting there idling and the
throttle's really sketchy right now so
man I don't trust that machine I think
I'm going to try to get back while I
still
can my camera mount just broke
everything is soaking wet everything is
breaking I think it's time to get out
while I still
can the
see me would be encouraging turn on your
heated seat two days
later all right it's been 2 days and I'm
back at it I'm in the same Valley as I
was the snow dog but I'm on a slightly
different path I don't want to have to
cross all those rivers in my
skis this Leed I'm pulling behind me is
called a pulk and it makes Winter
tracking really convenient but it makes
skiing really hard imagine having a 50
lb toddler pulling and pushing your belt
while you're trying to balance on skis W
like
that see how there's this random
clearing here with no trees this is an
avalanche Zone Avalanches routinely come
down that mountain destroy the trees
that's why there's very few spruce trees
here wo going downhill with that pulk is
always sketchy about halfway down you
get this violent shove from behind I'm
trying to take it real easy today my
knees are a bit junky I tore a pot my
left knee several weeks ago and it's
mostly recovered and I smashed my right
knee really hard on a snow machine
accident my knees feel good now but
that's going to
change there's the river I crossed with
the snow dog all
right I need to go ahead and get some
water this water's so clean I could
probably drink it straight but you know
I got a filter so why risk
it gravity pulls the water through the
filter fills up my jug when the filter's
new it does about a liter a minute it's
pretty quick once you're done you got to
go ahead and drain the whole thing if it
turns to ice inside your filter then the
filter won't
work woo that's it's
chilly oh that's Prett
PR got to take a little break and take
care of my
feet it's already kind of starting to
form it into a
blister I put some KT tape on
this I think it's time for a little
lunch break got this venison summer
sausage that A friend gave me on the
island of mikai oh it smells lovely yeah
that's
good
got to be really careful going down
these Trails the Moose like to walk on
the ski trails and they'll kill you
rather than get off
it I'm going to be breaking trail from
here on
out
navigating through these Woods is really
tricky it's like which way do I go if I
get on and off the path it's okay as
long as I can keep that River in my left
ear well things are going much slower
than anticipated but I already made it
several miles further than I did with
the snow dog unfortunately it's only
about 2 hours before Sunset and I'm
behind
schedule I just lost the basket on my
pole I have no idea where that went
without the basket it's really hard to
push off with your pole problem is
unless it's just sitting there on top of
the snow you're never going to find it
that thing is
gone got to take a little
break up to this point it's been
relatively flat from here on out I start
to climb into the pass breaking Trail
and pulling a pulk uphill is rough
try not to get my PK in the
water oh that's exactly what I did I'm
getting my stuff right in the
water pul tipped over and dumped my coat
right in the
water bent my ski pole
too it's already 3:15 and it's starting
to get
dark
yeah oh the PK trying to pull me down in
the
river I think I need to find a place to
camp and over there looks as good as any
other
place
that feels
good oh there's anything in the world
that feels better than taking off ski
boot
oh my goodness I think we're going to
get a lot of snow tonight curious to see
how this tar folds
up it is cold outside and it's getting
colder by the
moment time to make some
food
all right for dinner I'm having beef
stew I made it at home vacuum sealed it
then threw it in the freezer all I have
to do now is heat and
eat I got some Ling mui covered
mango all right got some hot Tang
here man the temperature's dropping like
a rock and I'm not moving around my
coat's a little wet oh I'm
cold got all the boiling water in my
thermos
here just going to go look at that oh I
needed that so bad let's go ahead and
eat some dinner got some sweet potatoes
and carrots and beef
chunks oh that tastes so good it's
warming my hands up
too I hit the spot but I am cold and
tired and I just want to get into bed I
need to level this snow out and make it
nice and flat so I can sleep on it don't
want to dig down too much cuz there's
all these sticks and trees and stuff
down
there wish I had my Caribou hides but
weight and space was such an issue I had
to bring this air air mat instead these
xed air mats are pretty good just got to
be so careful I don't poke a hole in
it so this right here is an emergency
bivvy it's just a waterproof shell that
slips over your sleeping bag if you're
in a storm it can be a good emergency
shelter and I see if I can slip my air
mat inside my emergency
bivvy well that should protect it from
popping
here we're going to put that hot water
bottle in
there wow we've got a lot of snow on the
roof
already oh
yeah I think I'm going to have to knock
that off before I go to bed otherwise
it's going to collapse on me in the
night have another glass of Tang before
I go to bed I'm dehydrated
I pulled the liner out of my ski boots
because it's a little bit sweaty I'm
going to stick it in the bottom of my
bag to keep it from freezing and then
when I put my boots on in the morning
it's not so
cold and it's time to get to
bed take my socks off so they dry in the
bag and won't get my feet
cold
all right guys I think I'm going to hit
the sack I am exhausted and I need to
get up and get out as soon as I can I
need to use up every ounce of daylight
tomorrow all right I'll see you
then it's 8:30 and about an hour before
Sunrise maybe hour and a half I think I
need to start getting ready I need to
take off as soon as it gets
light I like using flit and steel for
lighting my stove you can flick the
Sparks from afar instead of having to
get your fingers nice and close to
it for breakfast I've got a sausage and
egg omelet just like the beef stew I
made this at home and vacuum sealed it
now I just need to reheat
it my stove keeps going out I think the
head's gotten
dirty God darn it this thing is so weak
it's taking forever to boil I'm just not
getting
pressure that's Full Throttle right
there that's as much gas as I can give
it there's definitely something wrong oh
that's it I don't think it's going to
give me anything more I mean that's warm
enough I got some cheese sausage eggs
peppers
onions oh that was good if you're going
to carry your own water with you anyways
there's really no advantage to having
dehydrated meals versus prepared meals
and the Frozen prepared meals just taste
so much
better oh oh oh that doesn't feel right
oh
my right knee does not feel good oh guys
I am so falling apart this is a sign
that it's time for me to change I've put
a video out every Saturday morning for
the last 5 years without missing a
single week and uh I've done it when I'm
sick I've done it when I'm injured and I
work about 70 to 80 hours a week to get
that video out and I'm thinking it's
time to start putting out a video every
other week and I know it's going to
disappoint a lot of people who've made
this their Saturday morning routine but
it's time starting with this video I'm
only going to put out a video every
other Saturday but enough about that
let's talk about my current predicament
I have traveled about nine miles and
I've got about three more miles till I
get to the top of the pass you know I
don't want to get myself in trouble and
I don't want to hurt myself so bad that
I need three weeks on the couch to
recover so I think the safe thing to do
is to head back all right let's do
it
now yeah there you go that was a nice
little shelter worked out really
well see check it out on the bottom of
my skis I've got this synthetic fur back
in the old days they would use real seal
skin but of course now we use synthetic
stuff but the hairs all Point backwards
so it allows you to scoot forward but
you don't slide back and then if you
want to go downhill skiing you take the
seal skins off and they're just like a
pair of downhill
skis
pulk is trying to pull me off the
mountain every time that sled goes off
the trail it gets twisted around and I
have to stop and fix it I fix this pulk
and I know it's going to flip over on me
just in like 20 more feet the carabin on
my harness is all busted up I don't
think that Carabiner is going to last to
the end of the
trip sometimes S I get so frustrated at
my gear I forget to stop and look at
that
view oh my sled flipped over
again whenever the trail is all scampus
like this my pulk ends up flipping over
about every 5 10 minutes slows me down
so
much oh didn't even make it 5 minutes oh
my harness just broke too to gate
finally tore off this Carabiner it's
toast there you go kind of Jerry rigged
it with a piece of rope we'll see how
that holds we only have 7 hours of
daylight and so far the first 45 minutes
I've only done2 miles I've been working
on this sled and dealing with this sled
so much I know the train gets a little
better up ahead so maybe we'll pick up
some speed
there
every time we get to a slanty part the
sled just goes whoop and rolls over
they'll probably do it right here
too oh if I had a longer pulk I could
load it so that the center of gravity
was lower and it wouldn't flip over as
much but you can see right here how this
is all sloped off yeah my sled's going
to tip over a bunch over there well is
it tipped over already oh my other
Carabiner just
broke I got more rope so I can deal with
it come
on I think I need to change it
up putting this much weight on my back
makes me sink down further in the snow
and it puts a lot more stress on my
knees I've got this spot I need to
cross that worked a lot better than
expected and my sled's still upside
down I repacked the sled and they got it
a little bit more balanced seems to be
helping getting out of the trees doesn't
hurt either when I get these long
straight flat spots everything works
pretty
well
things are going a little bit better
sled's not tipping over as much let's
see can it do it
oh
yes oh that's pretty I think turning
around was definitely the right move I'm
going to be lucky if I get to my car
before
Sunset every once in a while I go down a
little Hill like that and nothing goes
wrong and it's really
nice well I've been going for 3 hours
without a break I think I need to eat
something man the temperature is really
dropping my fingers are
numb I can hear the highway I'm getting
close to the
car now I didn't achieve the goal I was
hoping for but I'm not going to leave
empty-handed well my wife asked me to
bring home a Christmas
tree my wife has very particular taste
in Christmas trees she likes them tall
skinny and quirky she has a type
that one's looking
promising it's not as big as I was
expecting but that's not a bad
one bu heads up oh wait we need to fill
we're a little short on Christmas
ornaments so we're going to use the boys
action figures there we go one Star Wars
Christmas
ornament I there we go there's General
Grievous perfect this video didn't go
quite the way I expected but hopefully
you guys enjoyed it if you guys want to
see more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe and activate your
notifications so you'll get notified
when we put out our next video all right
guys I'll see you in two weeks if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for
watching